Americans began receiving federal
stimulus checks this week but the
federal government is running out of
money to help small businesses cover
payroll during this pandemic CBS News
has learned that officials have already
approved at least 338 billion dollars in
paycheck protection program loans
Congress allocated 349 billion the Trump
administration says unless more money is
authorized it will have to stop
processing the loans and the latest
reports on unemployment indicate
millions more people have filed claims
for jobless benefits in the past week
and there's no surprise there most of us
are living under some form of a stay at
home order these restrictions are
putting a huge strain on the country's
economic health in our series on the
financial fallout from the coronavirus
we follow a dollar through the economy
to see why many economists think the
bottom could be a long way off with so
many Americans stuck inside these days
how are you very few of us are spending
money like we used to
that's especially true for the millions
of people now out of work but what
happens when there's suddenly so much
social distancing with our dollars I
work for CBS we're doing a story on the
economy if I keep my distance can I ask
you a couple questions last month
Denise Milhouse lost her job as a home
health aide in Brooklyn I'm not spending
money I don't have no way to pay my rent
did you have a favorite spot you would
go to Apollo right up the block on J
Street Apollo yeah so we walked over to
her favorite diner where she normally
spends about $200 a month
owner Mike misery ot says he's worried
that without income from customers like
Denise his business won't be able to
survive she'd love to continue spending
money with you but she lost her job so
she can I completers said she's in the
same boat of whatever 10 or 20 of my
other customers I've told me every
single day do you ever think that in the
same way that Denise is one of those
customers that means you can't go on you
for somebody else are one of those
customers it means they cap salutely
there's no way that I can ever recover
from the economic hole that I'm in right
now
the rent that I owe the mortgage
payments that I owe out and fixing my
business the my distribution bills my
utility bills it's either that or
chapter 11
among the cutbacks misery Otis is no
longer spending hundreds of dollars each
month at a nearby hardware store where a
manager told us business is down at
least 30 percent cascading losses like
these bouncing from a home health worker
to a hardware store illustrate how one
person spending is another person's
income and when that spending dries up
the ripple effects can be endless in
Collegeville Pennsylvania we found a
similar chain starting with Gina Katonah
two members of her family are now out of
work so she'll have to put off plans to
fix her broken down car I was saving up
to try to get it back I couldn't even
afford that at odhh before the shutdown
before they lost their jobs so now that
they lost their jobs it's never gonna
happen
and when her funds dried up the local
auto mechanic Ryan Miller lost his shot
at a payday 2 if I'm losing income then
I have to start cutting back on any
inventory I hold which one turn affect
the different local park companies
companies like Bob's Auto Parts where
Miller would normally spend up to two
thousand dollars in a month not this
month and that impacts owner Debbie
Dibattista along with the people who
work for her I've had to make tough
decisions
unfortunately layoff employees and it's
daunting it's you know it's a challenge
every layoff is an individual disaster
but also part of a widening national
crisis as economist Hank esken has
witnessed cash connects us all have you
in your tracking had bills travel to
every state in America oh yeah every
state every county in the country his
website Where's George allows people to
track the spread of money through the
economy using the serial numbers on
bills he says since the virus struck
hits on Where's George are down about 50
percent suggesting circulation is down
too the ripple effect will probably last
I'm guessing a generation or
two generations long after you know
we're gone it's still gonna be
recovering from this for now
Debbie Dibattista says the stress is
hard to bear
but there's solace in knowing she's not
bearing it alone it's not easy because
it's no one's fault my employees did
nothing to deserve this that repair shop
did nothing to deserve it the woman
whose car broke down did nothing to
deserve it everyone's working hard and
it's not like you're the only one you're
isolated talking to other businesses
other people helps you feel like
everybody has something in common like
this is something that we're all kind of
united together to try to get through
yeah we really are all connected by this
and and by the way Debbie they're the
auto parts store owner she has offered
to donate parts to help fix Jena
Katona's car one link up the chain and
she says anything that she can do to
help people like Janice she knows will
ultimately help her and will help her
employees recover by kick-starting this
cycle of business anthony yeah a lot of
charity out there Tony but I think
according one survey I saw nearly
three-quarters of Americans say their
income their income is lower because of
this so this just it just ripples out so
quickly as you just showed in that story
yeah and you know it occurs to me that
what's really important there is some
Americans who are in a position to keep
on spending I've been hearing from
people who say you know I'm still paying
the hair salon or I'm still paying the
gym because I can do it and I know they
need it right now I love hearing stories
like that if there are people out there
in their communities who are seeing that
that that happening go to our Facebook
page let us know I think it really
brings us all together